I could already tell with the jokes on
this trailer are going to be alright
Edgar it's out I thought this was a
sequel to unbreakable home with the hood
and he's a vigilante or you know the
Punisher looks great death wishes before
all that what is happening reject nation
it's Greg Alva here this videos company
is super late because I could not sleep
last night I am so nervous about my
upcoming match on the showdown against
top ten couldn't sleep but oh speaking
of which we're doing a live stream in a
few hours actually on our patreon
exclusive Q a different type where
everyone on patreon with a dollar pledge
they get it just ask us you know a bunch
of movie trivia questions and help us
prepare for the Natomas I know who
little soy boy whose book Death Wish the
remake
we all love remakes no one ever
complains about them and this one is
directed by Eli Roth and starring the
replacement for Charles Bronson Bruce
Willis the actor who really cares to be
in movies still wait in the morning say
for five we got to talk about what's
happening in Chicago there's a lot is
happening watch this viral video
designer loot eater calling the Grim
Reaper
you saw the car jacket is the rightful
taking the law into his own hands I have
a folk hero what about the shooter snap
a Lincoln Hank David Dunn turned in here
after I'm breaking into my house I've
been there who dis are out there
so the nothing that we do is that we say
if a man really wants to protect horses
and one about a gun he has to do is for
himself
hi we're closed whoa you're not gonna
kill me no Jackie's happens to cross for
me ice cream do you do ice cream school
of it okay
were you the last customer Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
I mean oh snap
let me original definition he was much
better getting in socializing hahahaha
well whatever you do keep it up good
[Music]
dang joe carnahan wrote that huh I
didn't know that I don't really remember
the original death wish all that much
the action film from the 70s I saw when
I was a kid I remember thinking it was
cool
I remember it being a lot more raw more
disturbing this feels like a cool action
film I think it's based on a novel I
don't really remember the Charles
Bronson movie all that well because I
don't really remember that one I feel
like I'm probably one of the people that
can have an easier time accepting what
I'm seeing here what I'm saying here
looks pretty fun this looks really cool
Eli Roth he's not the greatest director
in the world I feel like a lot of his
films are very over-the-top his actors
tend to be over-the-top as well
Bruce Willis looks like he's having a
really fun time with this role actually
I don't know be Larry I know everyone
knows Eli Roth to delve more into the
horror genre this film looks straight up
like an action thriller with comedy
infused in it I don't think I have to
remake death wish to make it exactly the
same I mean what's the point of remaking
if you're going to make it exactly the
same the tone and vibe feels different
and I like what we're getting here I
like these simple revenge type of
thrillers a terrible violent act happens
to his family then he starts seeking
revenge becomes his vigilante he's older
gentleman a guy you really wouldn't
suspect you know something as simple as
a dude who can just buy a gun one day
then started going on a rampage and I'm
wondering if he's going to deteriorate
into a serial killer because where I
remember about the first step which is a
terrible thing happens to this guy
becomes a vigilante he starts being
known as a hero but he's really just
morphing into a killer as the film
progresses and he gets progressively
darker I imagined the film
go down that path I would actually like
to see a trailer or just see it in the
movie itself with more of the Eli Roth
horror movie touches to it because this
guy tortures his criminals and there was
some cool tortured stuff happening there
when he slams that car on that guy
underneath it and a lot of the action
scenes look like they're shot really
well it's cool to see Eli Roth stepping
into a different genre so you have to
meet this one's like a fun action
thriller I would like to see more the
darker elements infused especially since
you got director Eli Roth in it I think
it'd be fun to see a hybrid of a fun
action movie with a lot of the dark
mentality that Eli Roth tends to provide
in his films as well and I feel like if
you're gonna do Death Wish you kind of
need that but for what we're getting so
far with the first trailer that looks
like a lot of fun all right guys you
except for this remake of death wish do
you wish they did remake it d I hate the
fact they played an ac/dc song over this
trailer whatever it is comment in the
comment boxes where your comments below
subscribe to the reel rejects click that
notification bell I'm the Greg Alva on
Instagram and Twitter we actually have a
real rejects Instagram not duck someone
took that we're real rejects on
Instagram the real rejects on Facebook
plug-in social media don't you guys love
to hear sluggy of patreon Rebecca